part of this is an attempt to it's not
just the idea of having no standards to
let people in but it's an attempt to
erase national boundaries and to
eliminate the nation state as the
organizing principle for for the world
order
uh
and uh and uh that that's why the
administration you know uh uh you know
basically does not protect our border
and it and talk about standards we have
like no standards i mean uh and uh
you know the the border is wide open um
you know so uh
you know that's where we are
but i agree with you certainly and and
throughout most of our immigration
history until recent days i mean even
including up until the clinton
administration you know we were supposed
to have standards and we were supposed
to be bringing in people who would make
a net contribution to the society and
immigration policy was supposed to
advance the interests of the american
people who are living here and help make
all of our lives better i was under that
impression so let's talk about russia if
i may because
as you're saying this i'm thinking
there's nobody more nationalistic
that has american pride as this
immigrant right here right
born in iran made in america and i found
that seems to be true with most
immigrants they're lucky to be here
they're happy to be here
like one of the conversations you have
with immigrants is you have no idea what
it's like over there in cuba in
venezuela in north korea with our friend
uh yomi park i mean we've we've
interviewed these people you have no
idea what's going on over there so it
you're talking about the immigration
policies it seems to me
that it's the
americans who are born here
that are the ones who are a little
anti-american if you will the the far
left of the uh democratic party they're
the ones in my estimation they're the
ones basically saying oh like we're the
bad people we're the bad guys they're
kind of been indoctrinated or ingrained
into this school of thought where the
immigrants are like dude you have no
idea what it's like out there could you
speak to that a little bit what are your
thoughts on naturally born american
citizens being a little more
anti-american than even the immigrants
you're referring to
probably a lot more anti-american than
the immigrants that they're referring to
those people who have experienced living
in authoritarian or totalitarian regimes
you know of course really appreciate
this country they've had in their own
lives the experience of what the
alternative is whereas
americans especially american college
students you know tend to come from very
comfortable middle class they've all
they've never had
had to live under a totalitarian regime
uh or an authoritarian regime uh you
know don't appreciate this country and
our educational system uh you know uh
from the high school level all the way
up uh you know has been has a as a has
become a big brainwashing machine for
leftist views which includes
anti-americanism
i remember when i was
in graduate school i mean uh and this
was back in the 1980s
you know i had the experience i mean
anti-americanism was basically being
taught back then even then and what year
was that oh uh this was uh
1983
sometime 1980 the early 1980s you're
saying anti-americanism was taught in
universities at this point oh yeah yeah
i mean uh the the there were uh there
were some conservative professors at
that point but the general uh uh
attitude was
well to give you an example
required reading in a uh in in one of
our
in one of our courses
uh his history is literature uh you know
was uh eldridge cleaver's soul on ice
okay uh cleaver was a black panther
you know violent activist
anti-american he wanted to
overthrow the government of the united
states and establish you know
you know a black
nation a separate black nation uh in the
old confederacy okay and uh and and his
soul his soul on ice book is a as a
diatribe against the racist evil america
and i remember and challenging the
professor who was teaching that book
because this was you know eldridge
cleaver's views trying to introduce us
and i said you know how come we're not
reading uh uh how we're not re come
we're not reading soul on fire
you know because uh
uh cleaver you know uh uh you know after
uh
i think he shot a cop or something like
that uh or committed some crime uh but
he uh he he uh escaped and uh and spent
many years uh living in russia
cuba uh you know uh uh
you know i don't think went to china but
basically uh authoritarian and
totalitarian regimes
and then he went to the u.s embassy and
and begged to come back to the united
states and uh and when the complaint and
even if he had his sp
serve served jail time okay
uh and when he got off the plane he
kissed the tarmac kissed the
literally kissed the ground at the
united states became a christian
uh you know uh and eventually ran as a
republican member of congress in los
angeles you know lost but his his soul
on ice you know is a warning to people
who used to believe as he did that
america is the greatest country on earth
that we should all be grateful here and
they did not teach that so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]